[Music]
Oh.
Peace TV, the solution for humanity.
[Music]
Oh.
We begin today's program with a
recitation from the glorious Quran.
Many
[Music]
come.
for
[Music]
the translation from Surah Nissa chapter
4 verse 59. 9 I seek refuge with Allah
from Satan the accursed
in the name of Allah most gracious most
merciful.
Oh you who believe obey Allah and obey
the messenger and those charged with
authority among you.
If you differ in anything among
yourselves,
refer it to Allah and his messenger. If
you do believe in Allah and the last
day, that is best and most suitable for
final determination.
I now request brother Ashraf to give the
introduction of brother Zakayak and
we'll go ahead with brother Zakai's
speech. Thank you very much brothers and
sisters.
Jazakah brother Sayyad Zakir Dr. Zakir
Nyak is a medical doctor by professional
training but he's internationally
acclaimed as a narrator on Islam and
comparative religion. Dr. Zakir
clarifies and clears misconceptions
about Islam using Quran, authentic
Hadith and other religious scriptures
which he quotes verbitim in conjunction
with reason, logic and scientific facts.
He's popular for his critical analysis
and convincing answers to challenging
questions posed by audiences after his
public talks. He has delivered public
talks in the USA, Canada, UK, Saudi
Arabia, UAE, Australia, South Africa,
Botswana, Malaysia, Singapore, Hong
Kong, Thailand, Guyana, South America
and many other countries in addition to
numerous talks in India. No wonder
Sheikh Ahmed Dat the world famous aator
on Islam and comparative religion has
given Dr. Zakir the title Didat plus.
Dr. Zakir Nyak appears regularly on many
international TV channels in more than
150 countries of the world. More than
100 of his talks, dialogues, debates and
symposia are available on DVDs. He has
authored several books on Islam and
comparative religion.
Dear brothers and sisters, before I
invite Dr. Zakin to speak to you on the
topic Sharia barbaric or perfect, I
would request him to gift a copy of the
Quran and its Tamil translation to
brother Dr. Shipman
[Applause]
Dr. Zak nag brothers and sisters on the
topic Sharia barbaric or perfect.
Alhamdulillah.
the respected people on the dash, my
respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters. I welcome all of you with
the Islamic greetings. Assalamu alaykum.
May peace, mercy and blessings of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala of Almighty God be
on all of you.
The topic of
this evening's talk is
Sharia.
Barbaric or perfect.
Sharia is the complete code of Islamic
law which pertains to the rights and
duties of the Muslim. It regulates
the lives of the people.
It is comprehensive
and includes
from the minute detail about eating,
drinking, clothing up to the complex
system of law making. The word Sharia it
literally means the clear path to
follow. The Islamic Sharia
it is derived from four sources. The
first source is the glorious Quran.
The Quran is the last and final
revelation of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
of almighty God which was revealed to
the last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. The Quran is
the word of God of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala and it is also called as the
furan the criteria to judge right from
wrong. The Quran was revealed by Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala by almighty God to
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
through Archangel Gabriel
1400 years ago
and it was approximately 23 years.
The Quran
contains 114 suras
or chapters
and contains more than 6,000 ayats,
signs or verses.
The glorious Quran was revealed in
Arabic.
But many scholars have translated this
glorious Quran, the word of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala into almost all the
major languages of the world.
This Quran, the word of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala is the highest and the first
source of the Sharia.
The second source is the sunnah.
Sunnah means the way of the prophet or
the doings
of the prophet according to the say
hadith the authentic sayings of the
prophet. The sunnah or the authentic
hadith are supplementary to the Quran.
They act as a commentary to the Quran.
It gives an explanation
to the verses of the Quran.
And in the sunnah
the commandments
of the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
comes on the top.
Then comes his actions
and many a time for the details
of his commandments
you may have to look into the life
of the sahabas. Allah says in the Quran
in several places including surah nah
chapter number 4:59 Allah says
obey Allah and obey the messenger obey
the messenger means obey the sunnah the
authentic sayings of the prophet and the
prophet said
that first look in the Quran
then look in my example
and his sayings and then
if you want more details is look into
the this generation then the next
generation then the next generation. If
you want to find more details about the
life of the prophet how he led the best
people who understood
the sayings of the prophet were the
companions were the sahabas those who
live with the prophet those who saw the
prophet and who died in the state of
iman. So if you want to understand the
hadith much better
if there difference opinion you have to
look in the lifestyles of the sales the
three generations. If you want to find
more details and more explanation
you can go into the lifestyle of the
Sahabas then the next generation then
the next generation that's it.
So the sunnah of the prophet the
authentic a hadith is the second source
of the Sharia. The third source is thema
that is the consensus of opinions
or the agreement
of the opinions of the sahabas of the
companions of the prophet followed by
the consensus of the opinions of safet
and the consensus of opinions of the
Muslim jurist of the first three century
of hijra.
If you cannot find the answer in the
Quran or cannot find any opinion in the
Quran then look in the sunnah of the
prophet in the authentic hadith. If you
don't find it there then you go to the
third source that is the
consensus of opinion. This is the third
source. And the fourth source is chaos.
Chaos means to judge and come closer
to make a judgment based on a reasoning
that if you don't find any direct
indication in the Quran or in the sunnah
of the prophet or in the
you can use your own logic to try and
find out the answer based on the other
verses of the Quran or the hadith of the
prophet or the
using analogy.
If direct there is no indication about a
particular thing
then you should look into the other
verses of the Quran and the Sunnah and
the try and find a relevant answer by
using analogy. But this can only be used
after the it can be used in Islamic
state where proper Islamic Sharia is
followed. Basically there are four
sources for the Sharia. Number one and
the highest in authority is the glorious
Quran, the word of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. Number two is the sunnah of the
prophet, the authentic hadith. Number
three is the number four is the kios.
The Islamic Sharia is a complete code of
conduct.
It gives a person a complete way of
life, how a life should be led. But
unfortunately
we find in the media and many critics of
Islam
they present the Sharia as barbaric
and
most of their allegations regarding the
Sharia most of them major of them they
revolve around two aspects.
One is the punishment in Islam.
They may show a poster or the front
cover of a book of a man being whipped.
Maybe the naked back is being whipped.
And the second aspect is women in Islam
that they are subjugated. They may show
a woman in hijab.
These two are the main factors which the
critics of Islam they attack the Sharia
and they say it is barbaric. And there
are a few others.
Time will not permit us to discuss all
the aspects of the Sharia. Neither will
time permit us to reply to all the
allegations and the criticism of the
media and the critics of Islam in the
limited time available. Inshallah I will
try and clarify a few of the
misconception of the Sharia. The first
as I mentioned most of the western
writers and the Islam they attack Islam
because of the way of punishment.
In Islamic law in Islamic Sharia the
punishment is barbaric.
Islam is a complete way of life and
compared to the other ways of life most
of the other religions if you analyze
they speak good things. most of the
religions including Islam. But the
difference between Islam and the other
religion is that Islam besides speaking
good things, it shows you a way how to
achieve that state of goodness.
For example, all the major religion of
the world, they tell us that we should
not rob. Hinduism says you should not
rob. Christianity says you should not
rob. Islam says you should not rob. So
what's the difference between Islam and
the other ways of life? between Islam
and the other religions. The difference
is that Islam besides telling us the
good things, it shows us a way how to
achieve that state of goodness.
In the Islamic Sharia,
we have the third pillar of Islam as
zakal.
That is every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level,
more than 85 g of gold, he or she should
give 2.5%
of that saving every lunar year in
charity.
If every rich human being gives charity,
poverty will be eradicated from this
world. There will not be a single human
being who will die of hunger.
And Allah says in the Quran in surah al-
Hashar chapter 59 verse number 7 it says
that zakat has been prescribed so that
it prevents the wealth from circulating
only amongst the rich.
So obligated charity is a part of the
Islamic Sharia. It's further all those
who are rich who has a saving of more
than 85 grams of gold should give 2.5%
of that saving every lunar year in
charity.
And after that if suppose someone robs
Allah says in the Quran in surah Maida
chapter number 5 verse number 38 as to
the thief beat a man or a woman chop of
his or her hand as a punishment from
Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
Many people will say chopping off the
hands in this age of science and
technology Islam is a barbaric religion.
It is ruthless faith.
And many people think that if they go to
Saudi Arabia where this law is
practiced, every second person they come
across,
they will see that the hands have been
chopped. Many people think that if they
go to Saudi Arabia where this law is
practiced, every second person's hand
will be chopped off. Believe me, I have
been to Saudi Arabia several times,
empty number of times. I have not come
across a single human being whose hands
have been chopped off. There may be a
few whose hands have been chopped but I
have not come across a single.
The law is so strict that a person will
think 10 times before committing the
crime. The Islamic Sharia is such it
gives you advice that don't rob.
But every human being will not follow
this advice.
Those who have faith in Allah may
follow. Everyone will not. So what
solution do you have for that? The next
solution is if they don't follow the
commandment of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
there has to be a punishment
and today America is supposed to be one
of the most advanced countries in the
world. Do you know it has one of the
highest rates of theft and robbery in
the world.
I am asking a simple question that if
you implement the Islamic Sharia in
America in USA that every rich person
who has a saving of more than 85 grams
of gold should give 2.5% of that saving
in charity every lunar year and after
that if anyone robs chop of his or her
hand as a punishment I am asking a
question will the rate of theft and
robbery in America will it increase will
it remain the same or will it decrease?
it will decrease. It's a practical law.
You implement the Sharia and you get
results. Therefore, I say that the
Islamic Sharia is perfect. We introduce
laws for results not just to be
mentioned in the books
and people may argue they think that if
you implement then you know how many
people are robbing oh there are
thousands of people robbing in America.
So do you mean you'll have to chop off
thousands of people's hand? The moment
you implement the law within a couple of
people all the rest God willing we stop
robbing because now they know that if we
arrested we can get through we can bribe
we won't get a severe punishment but the
moment the punishment is severe
a person will think 10 times before
robbing and immediately the rate will
come down and
people fail to realize that Islamic
Sharia is complete it's Perfect.
That doesn't mean that if a poor man
robs bread because he's hungry, his
hands will be chopped off. If a poor man
robs because he's hungry, it's the duty
of the state, the Islamic state to
provide food to him.
Why did he had to rob for food?
It is the duty of the ummah. It is the
duty of the people to see to it that the
neighbors don't go hungry. But natural
this punishment has it rules and
regulations that only if you rob a
particular big amount etc then it is
implemented and the question of a person
robbing food should not arise in Islamic
state
that's the reason the least state of
robbery in any part of the world it's in
Saudi Arabia
it's a practical law you implement it
and you get results
this was just an example of the
punishment and the logic behind this
punishment.
So people who worry that hands will be
chopped off the moment you implement the
Sharia the punishment need not be
implemented it may be implemented once
in a blue moon. The other point which
many skeptics they talk about Islam
mainly is about the women's rights in
Islam.
I will not permit to talk about all the
allegations
but in short
these critics they say that the women in
Islam they are subjugated
they don't have their rights they aren't
equal
in Islam men and women are equal but
equality does not mean identicality
they're equal but they are not identical
subhanah wa ta'ala our creator has made
the men and women biologically
different, physiologically different,
psychologically different. So depending
upon the psychological makeup, the
biological makeup, the physiological
makeup, Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has
given different roles for the men and
women
on many aspects. If you analyze,
men and women, they're equal. In some
aspects the women have a degree of
advantage. In some aspect the men have a
degree of advantage but overall they're
equal.
Let me give you an example that if in an
examination two students student A and
student B both get 80 out of 100. Both
come out first.
If you analyze the answer sheet the 10
answers to 10 questions each kind 10
marks. In answer to question number one,
student A gets 9 out of 10 and student B
gets 7 out of 10. So in answer to
question number one, student A has a
degree of advantage over B. In answer to
question number two, student B gets 9
out of 10 and student A gets 10 out of
10. So in answer to question number two,
student B has a degree of advantage over
student A. In all the remaining eight
answers both get eight out of 10. So if
you add up both get 80 out of 100.
Overall they equal
but answer to question number one
student a degree of advantage. In answer
to question number two student B are the
degree of advantage. Similarly men and
women in Islam overall they're equal. In
some aspects the women have a degree of
advantage. In some aspects the men have
a degree of advantage. For example, it's
mentioned in Sai Bkhari volume number
eight in the book of Ada chapter number
two had number two. Once a person
approached the prophet and asked him
that who deserves the maximum love and
companionship in this world? The prophet
said your mother. The man asked after
that who? The prophet repeated your
mother. The man asked after that who?
The prophet again repeated your mother.
The man asked after that who? Then the
prophet said your father. That means 75%
3/4 of the love and companionship of the
children
goes to the mother. 25% 1/4 goes to the
father. In short, the mother gets the
gold medal. She gets the silver medal as
well as the bronze medal. The father has
to be satisfied with the mere
consolation prize.
So in this aspect, if you analyze the
women have a degree of advantage. Why?
But natural because our mothers they
bore us in the womb for 9 months and a
prophet said even if you give them a
mountain of gold for what the trouble
they have taken for 9 months you cannot
compensate it. So because of that when
it comes to companionship
of the children the mother has a degree
of advantage.
Let me give you another example. Suppose
a robber if he enters the house I'll not
say I believe in Muhammad liberalization
I'll not tell my wife to go and fight
the robber
but natural as Allah says in the Quran
in surah Nisa chapter number four verse
number 34 that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
has given more strength to the men
so but naturally since Allah has given
the degree of advantage in physical
strength it is our duty to support and
protect the women. So here in strength
we have a degree of advantage. In many
other aspects
men and women are same. So in short this
was just a short reply to the
allegations
of the critics of Islam that Islamic
Sharia is barbaric as compared to the
women's rights in Islam. And for more
details you can refer to my video
cassette women's rights in Islam
modernizing or outdated.
As I mentioned earlier that most of the
religions basically they speak good
things but Islam besides speaking good
things it shows you a way how to achieve
a state of goodness
and
people object and they have different
opinion
how should the law be and one of the
common objection is that women they are
subjugated because of the Islamic hijab
and they say that the Islamic hijab it's
not modest at all it's not for modesty
it is for subjugating the woman.
And if you analyze and if you look
around us today in the world, the level
of modesty, it keeps on differing from
individual to individual depending upon
the surrounding and the society.
For example, in certain Muslim Arab
countries, even looking at a woman, even
staring at a woman is considered
immodest.
Here in India,
you can look at a woman, you can talk to
a woman. But if you touch a woman, it's
immodest. Therefore, the Indian sort of
greeting is with the folded hands.
As long as you don't touch a woman in
India, it is considered modest.
If you go to certain western countries,
shaking hands, men and women, men and
ladies, it's modest.
You can shake hands, you can talk, you
can stay, no problem. In fact, if a lady
puts a hand forward or if a gen puts a
hand forward and the opposite sex does
not shake hands, it's considered that
they are uneducated
or that they uncultured.
So there shaking hands is within the
modesty level. In some western
countries, you can even kiss a woman.
You can kiss a lady, a man can kiss a
lady on the cheek, on the lips, no
problem. It is modest. In certain
western countries, you can do what you
want. The men and women can do what they
want as long as they do with permission
of each other. It is considered modest.
So the level of modesty keeps on
changing. Now how will we human being
decide which is the best? Which is
modest. For example, if you go to USA or
go to the western countries, there a
young lady if she wears a mini skirt or
short she's considered modest.
But here that same lady comes or any
lady in India or in Madras wears a mini
skirt or short, she'll be considered
immodest.
Right or wrong?
Yes or no?
I was there in America a few years back.
There's the American who told me that
Indian woman, the Indian women, they're
immodest. I was shocked that how come
the Indian women immodest? He told me
that the Indian women they wear the sari
and they expose their belly.
So for the American exposing the belly
is immodest. And then I thought what
he's saying it makes sense for him
modesty level is that you should cover
your belly. Now we eastern people we
Indians we think we're very modest but
for the westerner exposing the belly is
immodest.
So who's to decide what is modest or
what is immodest?
The best one to decide is our creator is
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is almighty
god.
So let's analyze what is mentioned
in the Islamic Sharia the Quran and the
hadith about the modesty level and
people who lay an allegation
that Islam subjugates the woman because
of hijab. I would like to tell them that
if you go back in history at the time of
Babylonian
the Babylonian civilization they
illreated the woman if a man committed
murder instead of he getting the
punishment his wife was put to death. In
the Greek civilization
they had a concept of an imaginary woman
by the name of Pandora who was the cause
of all the misfortunes.
Though initially they believed in
chastity but because of ego